cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com here's the first story from
the New York Post
Burger King faces boycott after yanking
ads from Rumble over Russell Brand
accusations there's so much crammed into
this headline Russell Brand accusations
Rumble defends it Burger King boycotts
man that's like each of those things are
our big story is just piled on top of
each other they say though Burger King
hasn't publicly stated why it recently
removed its adverts on the popular site
just as other brands like Asos and
hellofresh recently did social media
users have questioned the timing of the
move which came just one week after
brand came under Fire the Whopper House
has since been bashed for pulling its
ads from the self-proclaimed Free Speech
platform before brand has actually been
convicted Burger King has pulled its
head for Mumble because the Free Speech
platform refuses to play judge jury and
executioner of Russell Brand after the
UK Governor demanded the platform
demonetize him UK governor who's that is
that a reference to somebody I'm not
familiar with that position in the UK I
know as a UK Parliament Member of
Parliament right yeah I think that's
probably a typo it was a member of
parliament yeah Member of Parliament
sent a letter out to all these different
Networks reminder Brad has not been
convicted of a single crime boycott
Burger King they hate free speech and
due process and their food is poison
anyway stop eating it I just want to
pause and say if you've been eating
Burger King for any reason
please don't I think Burger King is just
awful but that's just my opinion I mean
I'm not gonna besmirch the good name of
Burger King I guess is this Charlie Kirk
saying it's poison I wonder what the the
the legalities on that calling it poison
I think that's like I don't know if you
can say that but I guess it's an opinion
statement I think Burger King is
unhealthy and I'd I'd be I think it's
very would be very funny if Burger King
started suing people for claiming their
food is bad for you because it is bad
for you you know they're onion rings I
don't even know what their onion rings
are I gotta guess I think their onion
rings are potatoes no for real have you
ever had Burger King onion rings like
years ago I'm pretty sure it's I well in
my opinion it does not taste it's not an
onion like it's it's some kind of mashed
something or other they cut into a ring
yeah just not good anyway yeah here we
go this is the next story we have from
the guardian firms poll ads from Rumble
platform over Russell Brand video so
it's Burger King Asos and hellofresh
have removed these ads and now we're
getting people calling for a boycott of
these companies and this is uh in a
public statement plus an X Rumble called
the letter disturbing because the
government came out
so basically this is where we're at I
think what we're seeing here is actually
a move to begin to remove Rumble in the
story from the Sun they say I'm an
online expert Russell Brand's Refuge
platform Rumble may be forced offline
under new Internet safety laws
Rumble may go the uh parlor route what
do you guys think
I mean I think Russell Brand is
obviously being treated completely
unfairly uh you know he doesn't even
have a way to defend himself from these
allegations because there's it hasn't
nothing has been filed in a court of law
so other than
um Rumble support Rumble saying
basically you don't need to leave our
platform he doesn't have a lot of
recourse here and that's that's a
bizarre position to put in I mean what
is he going to do the question is will
are they targeting Rumble is are they
going to go after Rumble and try and get
Rumble taken down advertisers pulling
off the entirety of the platform because
Russell Brand is on it how does that
make sense
I think we need to figure out some sort
of way for people to just fund these
websites I I'm sure they're I'm not
familiar with Rumble but I'm sure that
they have subscriptions or things like
that but really really need to get back
to like users funding this because the
advertisers have so much power
true but the advertisers on platforms
like YouTube gave birth to the
influencer ecosphere it's a whole
generation of media that's really
disruptive I mean as much as you know
podcasts and alternative news really
it's the influencer web that uh drives
these things which for the most part is
predominantly funded by advertisers it
seems unfair that you know people
looking to have an alternative to
YouTube would not be able to participate
in
standard retail advertising dollars I
mean not that you should buy everything
in influencer sells on the other hand uh
they're in addition to unpersoning
Russell Brand there's an attempt to
unplatform rumble itself I buy a lot of
stuff off Instagram basically if
Instagram shows it to me I'm buying it
because because you know they're ripping
through my private data and the computer
out the algorithms know you better than
you better than you know yourself right
and so then you get this ad for like I
don't know this this UFO thing I got I
got an ad on Instagram for it and I was
like I must buy this and so I did and
then they added that shop feature to
make it easier creepy we really need to
commend uh Rumble for not giving in to
the Prussia campaigns that they're
probably feeling from every direction
right now
um YouTube should be condemned I think
is the strongest terms for demonetizing
Russell Brand based on
um accusations in the media where he has
really no recourse or ability to respond
other than through the media space
um and the BBC has been pressured into
removing old content that features brand
so he's losing royalties from there with
that said I I do want to caveat that I
think for all the people that that came
out have come out immediately in defense
of of Mr brand I I I'm just concerned
that the the backlash against
um I believe all women is is becoming
now the flip side of believe no women
and I I actually think that the Sunday
Times investigation was very thorough
and I think the allegations are credible
with that said though they are Anonymous
and they are placed entirely in the
space of a media PR battle not uh
through a civil lawsuit and no charges
have been filed in the criminal space so
for a man now
um who's having his entire career
unravel in a matter of hours it's this
is a it's a deep Injustice and it feels
I yeah I I don't find them credible I I
don't no I mean first I'll defer to you
I mean uh I've only have I only I've
only read the articles about them right
but my issue is if Russell Brand has a
relationship with someone no no not
Universal brand if a man and a woman
have a relationship and they argue with
each other and they fight
you can say that you know 20 years later
oh look here's here's text messages
showing them fighting him saying will
you apologize I know I acted poorly last
night and the Assa the assumptions you
can make based off of of
a 20 year old story
so this there's a text message between
Russell and this woman the reason why I
view this stuff as
I don't know I don't know uh not worthy
of news in my opinion is for one the
media absolutely loved everything he was
doing all that time ago people change
whatever if the argument is he shouldn't
do this well he's not doing it now okay
so it's been 20 years the issue I have
is let's say you Andy got into a fight
with someone and you texted them saying
it was really inappropriate what you did
last night I had demand an apology I
can't believe you would do that to me
and what happened he stiffed you on a
bill at a bar
and then it says like look when I tell
you this is how it's going down you
can't you can't do this to me I am
furious and this I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry and then later 20 years you're
like oh that text uh that was right and
it's like no no wait hold on that
touches about something totally
different it's 20 years later what do
you do the problem I have with these
accusations 20 years on is that
you can take a legitimate relationship
and then just say 20 years later oh that
was not consensual what how do you even
prove that I'm not I'm not saying like
there are challenges in the law but the
weirdest thing about how the law is
handled today is that when it comes to
murder there are cold cases where
there's a person who's been suspected of
the murder and we're like What do we do
and then people are like I don't know I
think he might be the murderer but we
really don't know but then when it comes
to issues like this it's like destroy
his life entirely because of anonymous
accusations
there's that the police are just now
opening investigation so
I suppose my point is it is almost
impossible for accusations this this far
this this old to be credible I don't
know what you do to make them credible
that being said
they there can be new evidence I'm sure
things can emerge when it's like a video
Russell made of himself where he's like
I can't believe that I actually did that
to those women last night it's true blah
blah it's from 20 years ago you're like
oh wow there's evidence evidence exists
for the time being they've only just
started an investigation so it's like
I'm sure man I wouldn't I wouldn't I
wouldn't I wouldn't call it credible and
actually I would I would at this point I
agree with you when you say it shouldn't
be believe no women it's true
but we're talking about believe all
women is supposed to be a woman goes to
the police the next day or maybe within
a week and you know she's traumatized
she's not to do and then she makes an
accusation we say okay we will believe
that we will operate under the
assumption the accusation is true and
correct and investigate it's not
supposed to be that 20 years later
someone comes out to the to the news and
the press and says oh that famous
celebrity yeah he did a bad thing to me
and then advertisers poll ads off a
platform because he's on that platform
none of this makes sense why would the
UK government try to get Russell Brand
banned that makes no sense that makes
the claims it strikes their credibility
outright like for sure you can make the
argument that the the Member of
Parliament was just exploiting a crisis
situation for political gain but it just
I just don't see it
um well
I think the actions of these third
parties who are now politicians
um activist groups online activists I
think their actions shouldn't
necessarily
um affect the credibility of those who
have come forward
um these are third parties I have their
own ulterior motives the the MP will
have her own reasons to try to elevate
her name profile and the process through
these type of actions as well as other
individuals who have um
Place pressure to try to destroy
um the career of a Russell Brand is just
I think um
uh you know I've been through
um I've been the the victim in
um or I've I've been through a trial
criminal trial where I was a witness who
testified uh and made allegations in a
criminal matter before and that process
I think has
it helped me understand potentially why
some victims don't go forward the
process of
um being cross-examined and gas lit and
reliving over and over a really
traumatic experience is it really
destroys you and that then kind of
opened my eyes to why I kind of
understand why some women for the first
time it made me understand perhaps why
some people don't immediately go to law
enforcement however that that doesn't
mean that I support them that decades
later years later then they go
anonymously to the Press yeah I got
don't care I I I don't play to this
emotional argument of oh it's so hard
and it's so emotional it you know it was
very difficult for people to do this
they say oh victims have a hard time
that sucks sorry have a nice day the
justice system is not supposed to be
your feelings are hurt so we're going to
destroy a man's life over it the justice
system is yes we recognize their
hardships we want to to seek the best
outcomes for justice that means if there
is a guy who is abusing women in large
numbers then definitely we're going to
try and solve for that problem however
if you as the victim are unable to
provide evidence and testimony in a
meaningful matter and with in in in a
Time appropriate manner then that's it
the legal system is not supposed to be
bent because some people have hurt
feelings I I will I do not accept that I
mean that's the UK I can't speak for
London I can say for the United States I
absolutely reject the idea that we would
have to put someone's freedom and
liberty at risk to protect the feelings
of another person because oh they felt
bad sorry you need to have evidence it
needs to be proven Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt and what we're seeing now is in
line with so many other BS moments
throughout the past couple of decades or
a decade or so where people have been
falsely accused and uh Julian Assange a
great example the media lied about
everything they use it to destroy his
life they didn't they didn't just fire
him they locked him up and they have him
locked up to this day despite the fact
we know the accusations that were made
were completely untrue so when you get
at Jeffrey Epstein who gets away with it
and gets protection from the media and
the press and then later it's like
whoops all of that was true forgive me
if I don't believe you when you go after
a Julian Assange and you you're you're
ignoring the people on your side and
you're targeting the people who are not
on your side all I see right here is
when when multiple agencies pull off
Rumble that's that that the Occam's
razor suggests a coordinated effort to
do so when Alex Jones got banned and I
think it was was it 2018 or was it 2019
2018. 2018. all the networks did at the
same time there's an argument to be made
that they were just waiting for uh you
know one you know Twitter is like as
soon as any other company makes a move
we'll do it too or
you likely have a scenario where there
was some political agenda in the
instance of Alex Jones we don't know
definitively but in the instance of
Russell Brand we know for a fact the UK
government solicited networks and and
platforms to remove Russell Brand so why
are these ads now being pulled from
Rumble likely because the same people in
the UK government are now targeting
anybody who's sponsoring Rumble I don't
think it's as simple as to say a couple
activists called Burger King and said oh
you know you guys are running ads on
Rumble now it's more like a national
security letter get sent out saying you
will do this now or else or maybe they
don't need it maybe a member of
parliament contacts your your head of
legal office with a Shakedown letter and
Burger King's like listen we do not need
Rumble 44 million users it's not worth a
permitting headache with the UK UK
government we're generating hundreds of
millions of dollars out of the UK let's
just let it go I don't know is Burt King
in the UK they're in the UK right I
don't think they make that much money
but that's that's my point if if right
now it's come to the point where you
have four women
who for whatever reason did not
you know come out with these allegations
and it's now 20 plus years later 10 or
20 years later I'm just like
you don't prove it that's all that
matters right you need proof give a take
as a criminal defense attorney yeah I
mean Tim's right you need proof you have
to meet a certain burden of proof uh
it's really hard to believe women 20
years after the fact so these situations
do occur I would encourage individuals
who are victims to report it as soon as
possible rather than waiting decades
down the line and you notice it always
happens when they're in the spotlight
for something or when they're leaning on
the right side because none of these
allegations were ever brought when
Russell Brand was like a darling of the
corporate media he was totally fine
nobody said anything now he's more
independent now you see them trying to
come after him and it just seems very
coordinated right they didn't say
anything when he made it married Katy
Perry
yeah why does the media care
how come the media did not care about
Epstein in fact they covered up for him
but they care so much about Russell
Brand I don't buy it not for one second
they all of a sudden care about Russell
Brand they all of a sudden need to have
the ads pulled they all of a sudden are
realizing his shows have to get pulled
off the BBC Channel 4 and YouTube or
whatever
what
I don't buy it sorry have a nice day
Epstein they knew Epstein had been
charged and I think it was like in the
2000s they knew what he was doing he got
a sweetheart deal and was let go
so so where was the media on this one
now you can argue that Epstein was
blackmailing powerful individuals okay
where was the media because this Expose
and Russell Brand is the Sunday Times
it's channel four all of a sudden one
day
somebody at these networks they're just
like you know I'm really concerned about
Russell Brand I'm gonna go dig around
for 20 year old accusations
what someone started so you have to
understand this someone started some
journalist decided to start soliciting
past relationships of Russell Brand to
to and ask them about issues of
impropriety
why
no I mean for real look if he was doing
these things that's bad for sure but
it's a weird thing for the media to
immediately want to pick up especially
when it's coming from from corporate
narrative establishment government media
sources quite literally
so
it seems weird and he's in an impossible
position because there's nothing going
on in court right so he could file let's
say a defamation suit maybe against
these Anonymous people but then he is
adding to this narrative that he is the
aggressor right he's going after these
theoretical victims who aren't even
being named and therefore he's trying to
get lots of money like there's no good
look for him in this scenario I get what
you're saying I think I agree I think it
is complicated for a lot of people to
decide to go through the trial process I
don't think cross-examination is easy uh
but the fact that this was solicited
from a reporter is so strange yeah I
mean what what me too I think has done
is it's a it's giving an excuse It's in
many ways actually discourage victims to
um
to speak out whenever when they want and
to who they want like the media rather
than
to law enforcement I think law
enforcement Inc reporting is so key for
victims to get Justice when you I mean
when you wait so many years in statutes
limitations policy memories is blurry
evidence is lost and destroyed
it's just yeah the metoo has been more
about I think
um
giving space for people to tell these
stories where they can actually never be
falsifiable and that's you know there's
and in that case you can never even wait
for a due process to play out I see a
lot of people responding like SunTrust
responds on social media we should uh
withdraw withhold judgment and wait for
just uh this process to play out but
there is no process playing out so it's
I reject all of the uh accusations and
allegations against Russell Brand all
right
I mean it's it's a pattern in but one of
them went to a Rape Crisis Center at the
time and and considering the political
state of this country considering the
actions being taken against them
considering the motivations of the press
sure but I won't give the benefit of the
doubt sorry not happening it's just
there there's there it's there are so
many bad people and criminals who are
getting away with everything that what
we end up seeing is law enforcement
choose to go after certain people when
it benefits them politically that's the
nature of the West today so when I see
20 year old accusations it's Brett
Kavanaugh all over again sorry don't
care at all you want to investigate you
want to prove it by all means please do
so you prove it in a court fine I get it
but now does anyone actually even
believe these courts you got Donald
Trump and that story that woman in New
York that he went to that department
store which is yeah right what was the
department store uh Bergdorf Goodman's
right yeah Goodman's and it's the
busiest place with the most famous man
arguably in the city nobody owns the
hotel next door nobody noticed Donald
Trump with no security going into the
second floor I think it was and and then
and then a New York jury finds Donald
Trump accountable liable for for this
this assault or something sexual assault
yeah that's insane that's insane so by
so sure fine still don't care I don't
care I think the silver optimization of
it is just so so thick and so intense
I'm giving no one the benefit of the
doubt I think the Silver Lining from the
Russell Brand Story is that people who
care about free speech and due process
are actually standing up and they're
boycotting these companies who are
pulling uh pulling funds from Rumble
advertising I think it's really good to
see the conservative boycotts that have
been happening all year uh it finally
feels like we're trying to make our
voices heard yeah yeah see the issue is
every single time
something happens
or I shouldn't say every single time but
typically there have been major
political moments over the past several
years and you get conservatives
Libertarians and post-liberals all
trying to do the reasonable thing
okay like you said oh we'll hear this
one out and what happens bunk turns out
to be nonsense
I remember uh when George Floyd The
George Floyd video came out and we all
were like yeah that video is bad like
that should not have gone down that way
and then you you get the body camera
footage and learn a lot more about what
was really happening and now you're like
okay so it's it's tragic but
it's a bit different than the way they
put it the original video of George
Floyd is a guy being he's on the ground
and they're kneeling on his neck and he
dies and it's like whoa then you learn
the dude was chewing a speed ball behind
the wheel of a car the police brought
him out Floyd demanded bagged and
screamed to get me out of the car and
put me on the ground he had a cocktail
of of drugs in his system still he
should have been given proper medical
treatment
you know but it's nowhere near what
actually went down Ahmed Aubry is the
most egregious the people who I I know
conservatives who still don't know the
the real story of what happened with
Ahmed Arbury and the McMichaels and
we've had people on this show come on
and be like well the armadar brewery
thing that was Justice I'm like are you
kidding did you even watch that I'm sick
of this Russell Brand in in the
corporate press and in the movies is
celebrated oh this woman went to the
police I'm glad she did if there's
evidence that comes out so be it the
Russell Branch go to prison if it's true
but not police the Rape Crisis under
okay well then I don't believe it sorry
I like you need evidence to to convict
somebody you know there's a lot of
things people can do and there's a lot
of fake things people do but my point
ultimately
we have spent all of our time giving the
benefit of Doubt to so many different
people who are evil at this point I'm
just like you know I don't know maybe it
was 20 years ago you prove it we have a
story if not I I think it's
it's being used to uh Target Rumble it's
being used to stop Russell Brand from
producing high profile high traffic
anti-establishment media
and that and they're pushing a
conspiracy theory that the only reason
Russell Brand actually opposes the
establishment is because he was trying
to build up a base to protect him from
accusations against them it's it's
psychotic total BS sorry not I'm not
buying it thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time